eine ukrainische
aufklärungsdrohne überfliegt einen
bauernhof im süden des landes bei
recherchen nördlich der krim neben
landwirtschaftlichen geräten entdeckt
die drohne halb unter einer plane
versteckt einen russischen b mp3
schützenpanzer
der panzer hergestellt in den achtzigern
zu sowjetzeiten wird anvisiert und aus
größerer entfernung geschossen er
explodiert
der riesige feuer bar lässt vermuten
dass der panzer mit vielen munition
beladen gewesen ist bild militärexperten
ordnen die bilder als echt und aktuell 1
warum der panzer unter der plane
versteckt auf dem bauernhof parkt und
nicht im einsatz ist unklar erneut
gelingt es den ukrainern den russen
einen panzer zu nehmen durch das
zusammenspiel von drohne und schwerer
artillerie
die für den kampf gegen putins truppen
und für die freiheit der ukraine
unverzichtbar geworden ist